what do you think about elon spacex
nasa we put humans back up uh
back up there my theory so
it's funny because i i know one of the
guys that was he was he was one of the
original employees at spacex
he's a friend of mine and i won't say
his name but he knows elon
yeah he knows elon and uh yeah and he
actually worked on the entire falcon 1
project he's one of the lead guys on
that so he's got some great
matter of fact he's there's a movie
there's a book coming out that comes out
in about a year on this
the original the first years of space
first six years of spacex
you know and he's named in the book you
know and they're supposed to make a
movie on it so i'm like hey who's gonna
play it
um but uh what he's done to me it
changed the game and here's why
because i said you know in i think it
was 62 and eisenhower warned of the
industrial defense complex you know
which
it has become everything he warned us of
you know
it has become and it's really driven by
there's the big three in defense which
is really you know northrop
lockheed and boeing those are the big
those are your
biggest raytheon's kind of right like a
subset of that but they're
raytheon's pretty big too big in u.s
defense those are the big guys
right that's actually where a lot of
military guys go when they retire they
go do stuff like that so
um when you look at that and you go and
the way government contracting is
working and how we charge and
you know why things cost so much and
then you go you got
elon who's got an ego you know and he
doesn't like to do things certain way
and i've talked to the guy that worked
there
on you know because the government likes
to have oversight of contracts where he
was like no
just tell me what you want i'll build it
i'll give you a bill when it's done and
then if i do it for half the price i
make a ton of money
because he's money-driven guy which i
like capitalism at its best
so now you look at the two things so you
got the the spacex which is the dragon
capsule
right and then you've got boeing so elon
did what boeing is contracted to do in
less time for half the money
and oh by the way because he can reuse
the boosters because they come back and
land and you don't have to like morton
thai call we reused them on the space
shuttle
but they had to take them all apart and
do a bunch of stuff because they landed
in salt water and then you had to put
them all back together
where elon gets them down because i was
joking with this guy go what do they do
do they like
re re-haul you know overhaul because no
actually they clean them up and they can
use them again they're reusable
systems incredible leap in technology
that no one thought of but here's a
private company so being able to put
people on
in the capsule and the spacesuits i mean
it's literally like sci-fi when you
watch
when they went up so i'm a huge fan of
what he
and his company have been able to do
because you know the fact that we were
paying huge amounts of money
to the russian government you know and
oh by the way if you didn't know because
i have some friends that are astronauts
uh they all have to learn russian right
they have to and they have to do it's
what level five where the test is a
phone call
yeah where they call you up and they you
know because they would go
so i went to the pinning and two two
friends of mine
the one actually had a mission date the
one got one later so it's cool when
you're watching your friends doing a
spacewalk
you know because i would pull up because
if i knew it was going on i'd pull up
the nasa thing i was in a meeting one
day and i've got nasa on
and and makers out there floating around
you know doing his stuff and i saw one
he's in the space station while they're
doing a spacewalk so it's kind of cool
when you go oh yeah i know that dude
he's up there in space floating around
um so when you when you look at what
those they're capable of doing and then
you go
what elon is bringing to the fact that
now
it's back in america it's actually
to me it's it's cost effective for us to
be able to do more stuff
i think it opens the door to do we go
back to the moon is there a reason to go
back to the moon personally i think if
we're gonna if they're really gonna go
you know in years from now go to mars i
think that the moon is the stepping
stone to go back
to start proving some of the technology
to go hey we can build this we can get
on the moon
and now we can get back off the moon
because we did this on a less than a
compact computer in the 60s which is the
whole reason that i flew
because i'm obsessed matter of fact i
have the giant lego apollo at home
and the lander and i have one that my
dad built me in 1969
right after that and neil armstrong's an
ohio boy and so am i
matter of fact i have a picture of him
in a car in wappa connect ohio at the
parade after he walked on the moon
because his parents didn't live far from
my aunt uncle in wapakaneta and they
were out at the parade
so i've been obsessed with this since i
was a child do you hope to uh
do you think do you hope that you'll go
out to
the space one day me if i had the
opportunity i'd go in a second
you know i am not i mean that's one of
the hopes of the commercial space flight
is that
you know like people like i mean it
would be to us
tourism but you certainly wouldn't want
to in terms of you're now
kind of a civilian right i mean in a
sense that you're just a normal person
you're not a fighter pilot
currently but it seems like if we send a
civilian up there would be somebody like
you
in the next like 20 years i i'd be you
know if eli wants to throw me one of
those things i'd be all over it i don't
know what my wife would say but you know
sometimes you gotta
you gotta get your kicks while you're
alive i'd love to hear that discussion
with your wife listen there's the pros
and cons
uh she's she's i mean i've known she's
on board high school so she
yeah she knows how i am you know most
people that know me are like yeah you're
pretty much the same person you were in
high school
i was a class clown and i still am that
way
you